many anxious parents have a new concern
as their kids go back to school here's a
question how will they get there a
nationwide bus driver shortage is
causing delays and adding to family
stress so we sent errol barnett to
maryland to find out the root of the
problem and how the school districts are
trying to fix it errol good morning i
don't like saying we sent you i think
the word is you said i want to go to
maryland to do this story about school
bus driver shortages is that how it went
100 correct gail good morning to you
look you know i spoke with someone just
yesterday who told me these big boys
behind me are not the problem there are
some 1270 yellow school buses ready to
go to get public school students
to class here in prince george's county
when classes resume the issue is pay and
the pandemic with many existing drivers
re-evaluating the risks they take for
what they make and with schools ramping
up nationwide this is clearly becoming a
problem everywhere
i'll keep saying it until the cows come
home we need more drivers in lee county
florida parents are being told to expect
significant school bus delays for the
foreseeable future and in chesterfield
virginia a request for parents we're
asking you to please drive your child to
school one charter school in delaware is
offering 700 dollars per student for
parents who bring them in i work two
jobs
i can't get them to and from school
every day meanwhile pittsburgh public
schools told parents nearly 800 kids
will have to walk my sister was not
going to walk here even with a group of
people it is a patchwork of policies
stemming from a lack of new bus drivers
it has always been an issue the
difference is right now the numbers are
probably double what they normally would
be at this time a year or more in terms
of our need rudolf saunders oversees
transportation for the more than 130 000
students in prince george's county
maryland and says his network is under
pressure puts us in a situation where
you might have to condense her out by
adding two routes on the same bus so
there's more kids on the bus which is
why four figure cash incentives are
emerging
in atlanta one thousand dollar bonuses
are on the table for new hires while
baltimore city is willing to give three
times as much the shortage is so dire in
montana helena public schools are
offering a four grand bonus saunders may
follow suit coven is exasperated the
challenge for school bus districts and
school districts all around the
president of napt which represents
school bus drivers says the pandemic is
partly to blame a health risk for the
often older drivers you don't typically
find people that are 18 to 25 driving a
school bus it's people of age
that are in their 40s or later and some
of them may be afraid to get on the bus
because of covid and the students that
may or may not have been
vaccinated this is easier than driving
your car why is that
you can see
everything
bus driving instructor johnny walker
trains new drivers for prince george's
county schools that's the most important
job
in the system because
without getting those kids to school and
getting those kids to school on time you
know they're missing
education
now napt estimates tens of thousands of
school bus drivers are needed nationwide
right now and it would take roughly six
to eight weeks even if there were an
influx of applicants today to get these
folks trained up to get their cdl their
commercial driver's license so that
would be october schools here anthony
and prince george's county resume next
month
errol thank you very much we've heard
about the teacher shortage there's a bus
driver shortage too what about that i
like that driver's take on it though
it's one of the most important jobs that
you have right it sure is yeah and what
a bonus for parents or somebody who
wants to drive their kids seven hundred
dollars per child yeah but a lot of
parents just don't have time yeah or
step up and be a commercial driver and
get thousands yeah